Alabama's Republican Senate candidate
Roy Moore is under pressure to drop out
over sexual misconduct claim for women
tell the Washington Post that Moore
pursued them when they were teenagers
and he was in his 30s and one of the
women was 14 years old at the time all
four have confirmed their stories to CBS
News White House press secretary Sarah
Huckabee Sanders reacted to the report
overnight while traveling on Air Force
One a mere allegation in this case one
for many years ago to destroy a person's
life
however the president also believes that
if these allegations are true
do the right thing and step aside more
calls the allegations baseless political
attacks but they are the newest
bombshell in a Senate race that was
supposed to be easy for the GOP Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill where more is
all getting almost no support Nancy good
morning good morning Republican leaders
were already uncomfortable with mores
far-right views on Muslims and
homosexuality and a host of other issues
now they are actively looking for ways
to replace him in this race but their
options may be limited it's a
devastating nasty story the uneasy truce
between Roy Moore and the rest of the
GOP fell apart Thursday you should step
aside if the allegations are true but a
defiant Moore reportedly called the
allegations quote filthy and sleazy
attacks by forces of evil
urging god-fearing conservatives to help
him fight back by chipping in a donation
abortion sodomy sexual perversion sweep
our land Mohr's accusers say the
outspoken evangelical sought them out
when they were as young as 14 wendy
miller says more a stir out on dates but
her mother said no Lee Kaufman says
Moore kissed her took off her shirt and
pants and guided her hand to touch him
over his underwear at the time he was 32
we're all created an image of God more
defeated Alabama's appointed senator
Luther Strange in the primary this fall
with the help of president Trump's
former chief strategist Steve Bannon one
the finest men in this country judge Roy
Moore last night at a conservative
gathering in New Hampshire Bannon
compared the allegations against Moore
to the Access Hollywood tape that
surfaced right before president Trump's
election but did not bring him down it's
purely part of the apparatus of the
Democratic Party they don't make any
bones about it it's not a fair and free
media anymore
Republicans worry this scandal could
open the door for a democratic pickup in
deep red Alabama but it is too late at
this point to replace Moore's name on
the ballot they could try run
someone else has a write-in candidate
but that's always risky especially Yale
since Moore himself has shown no
intention of dropping out certainly more
to come on this story thank you very
much Nancy